[Music]
do
are we good am i on no
hello check check
check check are we good
oh that's better hello
hi everyone so good to see you
i see some new faces that i haven't seen
before um
my name is karen miner i'm part of the
elder leadership team here at the table
welcome this is my first time back
actually in this building in over a year
so yay it feels good it feels good i'm
gonna see if i remember how to do this
because i've been in front of a screen
so i also want to take time to welcome
those of you that are watching online
uh really really glad that you're with
us as well
and uh i just have a couple of
announcements to get us started tonight
uh first of all we are having our
welcome to the table class
and i believe some of you are signed up
for that yes
yeah so it's gonna happen as soon as
we're done with the service
uh right at 6 00 pm and what you're
going to do is you're going to meet
brett right over by this
exit door so meet with brett right over
here and then you'll go in
we have sandwiches for you to keep you
nourished through the class because we
understand it's going through kind of
the dinner dinner
time if you are interested in the
welcome to the table class
and you haven't had a chance to sign up
don't worry
you can still be a part of that class if
you'd like
um just come see brett after the service
and he will get you set up for that
basically this class talks about our
values our vision our beliefs
where we've been where we're going and
helps you learn more about how to get
connected and also if you'd like to
become a member at the table you'll get
that information as well so it's just a
good way to
get up to speed on the table and figure
out how to be a part of it if you'd like
to do that
also for those of you watching online
this is for you as well
that class is happening online at 7 30
pm
and again if you haven't had a chance to
sign up for that in advance don't worry
you can do that
the best way to do that is to email
brett and you can email him at bret
at thetabletx.com so
that is our welcome to the table class
we're doing that quarterly
correct every quarter so if you don't
make it to this one there will be
another one coming up
both in person and online so
as we transition into worship which i
can't wait for because
we have these lovely ladies leading us
tonight uh let's take time to just
settle ourselves take some deep breaths
remember where we are and why we're here
what brought you here
remember that you are loved you are
accepted here
and this is time just to be you don't
have to do anything
just be so let's pray
god thank you for tonight thank you that
we get together
together it feels like such a privilege
after so long being a part
so god we acknowledge your goodness your
kindness your love that never fails
your love that never leaves us
we center on you tonight
[Music]
help us to receive whatever it is you
have for each one of us
and i do believe you have something for
each one of us tonight that's very
specific and unique
so god help us to be open to that open
our hearts
our minds god help us to
just truly receive what you have and we
thank you
it's in jesus name that i pray amen
[Music]
it is so great to have you back
and it's good to be back with you guys i
was out last week
because i had a little mouth surgery and
i was confessing to marissa earlier that
i am the world's
largest baby when it comes to liquid
diets
i hate them with a passion i didn't know
it
but um i would almost prefer any other
sorts of pain
over eating liquid diet for two full
weeks so
if i sound hangry in this set it's
because i am
[Laughter]
and i have all these stitches in my
mouth that are rubbing blisters
so i also feel just awkward talking to
you guys like i'm talking around
you know when you're a kid and you put
rubber bands in your mouth to pretend
like you had braces
that's what it feels like right now you
were the only ones who did that
yeah did other people do that or were we
just just you i thought this was a
universal experience
that people had in childhood
well we probably all did it together
because we're all sisters if you guys
haven't met
melody and maggie and i'm mindy
and we're really glad that y'all are
with us so um if you want to stand
um we're gonna spend some time just
worshiping a god who is
for us and with us and um yeah i hope
that that is
a god that we can all engage and
encounter together tonight while we sing
[Music]
sing this with me this is a call to
all the dead and disappointed
the ones who feel like they are done
this is a word to all the ones who feel
forgotten but
you are not no
no you are not
we're alive alive alive
and we're singing we're alive alive
alive and we're shaking we're alive
alive
alive alive in you
we are soaked in all the grace that
we've been
given unchained from all that we have
done
your mercy's rising like the sun on the
horizon is
[Music]
oh
alive alive
[Music]
i
am
[Music]
this is a call to all the dead and
disappoint
the ones who feel like they are done
this is a word to all the ones who feel
forgotten
but you are not
[Music]
sweet love of mine
and may these
stretch across the sky
these hallelujahs
be more
your love is
like radiant diamonds
[Music]
your love will
singing your name
[Music]
i have surrendered
stretch across the skies
these hallelujahs
these offerings
stretch across the skies
these hallelujahs
hallelujah hallelujah
[Music]
sing hallelujah
hallelujah hallelujah
hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah sing hallelujah
hallelujah hallelujah
hallelujah
[Music]
[Applause]
i have surrendered
to your design
and may this offering
stretch across the skies
[Music]
hallelujah
hallelujah hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah
hallelujah hallelujah
ah jesus thank you so much for this time
together
so beautiful to hear people's voices
joining in
to worship a god that is good
oh my god who cares about us
tonight we're going to try something a
little bit different it's um
a tradition in so many christian
histories
um and it's referred to as prayers of
the people
um the way it's gonna go is i'm gonna
say a short prayer to start us
off and begin with and then
i'm going to open it up to any of you
who would like to
speak out the name of someone that might
be on your heart tonight
we all have people in our life that we
know are going through so much
and dealing with difficult times or
maybe a relationship that you are
working extra hard at repairing right
now or
whatever the case might be um we all
have those people
that we're surrounded by um so it's just
a time for you to speak out their name
um you don't need to give any details as
a matter of fact probably to protect
their privacy since they're not giving
you permission
probably better to just speak their name
out you know um
so for instance if it was one of my
sisters i would just say
maggie and that's all you need to say is
just their name
um and then after a few minutes
you know or however long it takes for us
to share those names then i will
finish out with a closing prayer and
wrap it up but i just
encourage you guys to engage this time
with us
um it's it's a really beautiful thing as
a community when we can come together
like in solidarity on behalf of those
who we know are needing
extra grace and love and redemption in
their lives or healing
so um yeah i just encourage you to be
bold and brave and
enter this with us if you would like
jesus for the city of saxi texas and for
every city
and community and all of those who live
in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it
we pray to you
[Music]
for those who travel on land sea
and air we pray to you
for the old and the sick and the widow
and the orphan for the injured
and the suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed the destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember
and care for them we pray to you
and lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us
and so now we lift these names
up to you
[Music]
johnny
nikki parker
[Music]
rachel
jesus for those names that we've spoken
aloud and for those
that we hold in our hearts we pray
to you that they may have
life and light healing
and hope peace
and a deep sense of your presence
[Music]
amen
there's a grace when the heart is under
fire
another way when the walls are closing
in
and when i look at the space between
where i used to be and this reckoning
i know i'll never be
alone there was another
in the fire
standing next to me
there was another in the waters
holding back the seas
and
[Music]
there's a cross that bears the burden
where another died for me
there's another
[Music]
oh my dear lefty dead beneath the waters
what remains of me and this reckoning
either way i won't bow to the things of
this world
here we go
i know i will never be
alone there is another
in the fire standing next to me
there is another
[Music]
set me free there
and the
[Music]
shake beneath us as the prison walls
cave in
nothing stands between us
[Music]
there is no other name but the name that
is jesus
[Music]
he who was and still leaves and will be
through it
[Music]
i know i'll never
you'll be
[Music]
cause i know that's where you'll be
between
[Music]
nothing stands between
between us
nothing stands between us
and nothing stands between us
nothing stands between there's another
[Music]
there's another in the waters
holding back the
and should i ever need reminding
of how good you've been to me
i'll count the joy come every battle
cause
[Music]
i'll count the joy come every battle
cause i know that's where you'll be
god i'm just reminded of the times
where my own pain
felt so overwhelming that i couldn't see
a light
where i couldn't even believe for myself
that there was something on the other
side
but how we were surrounded by such a
great cloud of witnesses who were
believing
for us who were seeing a light
when i felt blind
i came with your sweetness your kindness
your goodness your compassion god and
you
lifted us of a pit and you set us on a
rock
god would we be that community for
others
and for anyone who's with us in this
room tonight or online watching
that feels blind that feels so
overwhelmed and overcome by their own
pain god tonight
would you be a healing bomb that flows
down from heaven
god into their homes into their
relationships
their parenting their marriages their
addictions
god whatever it is that's creating a
wall
god a gap a chasm between you and them
would your love bridge that gap
god would our prayers and our love
bridge that gap
thank you that you're a god who rescues
you our god who meets us in our pain
who walks with us in it god who shares
it
who has gone before us and knows the
other side
you jesus god we hold out a hope for the
[Music]
we believe for our brothers and sisters
and our friends
and our family right now
thank you god that you're a belief
you're a god worth believing in
you have shown yourself worthy and true
we love you and we thank you for this
time together
amen
well on that note why don't we turn
and just greet the people around us with
a wave
a nice hello to the people around us and
if you're joining us online
we invite you to just leave a quick
comment and say hi
there as well so love you guys thank you
so much brett's gonna share now
all right well that was beautiful
beautiful it's good to um just to
worship god
you know it's um it's been a long year
and um yeah so it's just good to
to be here to be together um so thank
you thank you for that time and thank
you um maggie mindy melody for
um just giving us that gift beautiful so
um i want to welcome all of you
especially those of you who are new i
know it can take a lot of
courage to walk through those doors and
you know come into a new place
and i'm like oh gosh so yeah thank you i
appreciate you doing that
and i also want to again welcome those
joining us online
our extended table family love you a lot
you guys can give them a wave um and uh
yeah we've got people really um kind of
scattered like mostly in the area
but even you know in a few other states
and people who like tune in really
consistently
and are consider this their their home
in a way so
um that's beautiful um so
we are in um part two of our series
titled new normal new normal and
um this well i mean i have to tell you
it's been quite a year
uh pretty challenging uh 12 13 months
we've all been going through
and um kind of the the premise of this
series
is that um hiding in the all the
challenges and the difficulty of the
past year
um hiding within it is a tremendous
opportunity
and uh i i i think this is true i mean
there could be a number of reasons this
is true but one that comes to mind is
um there is a family or he was a family
therapist named
murray bowen um and he kind of came up
with this family systems theory his kind
of one of his ideas was basically that
every relational system which a
relational system would be i mean like a
nuclear family
um even just a marriage like two people
it could be like a church
community like this a business even a
city it's sort of like anywhere you have
relationships happening his idea was
that um when you have a relational
system it craves
um homeostasis i mean it just it craves
stability sameness like let's just keep
doing the same old things
in the same old ways um and you can kind
of see how this plays out because i mean
i mean think of even when someone in
like your little family system or your
relational system
is like trying to make changes whether
it's the boss like hey we got some
changes coming down the pike or
um you know even in a marriage or or uh
in a relationship like where someone's
like hey i need to
i just i want to make some new changes
like even if they're good ones you know
like i just i need to get my diet like
going and we got to make some changes
around here
and you know immediately even if it's a
positive thing it's kind of like
and why is that because it it disrupts
the system you know and and we don't
like that like we just like
the same thing now um so why does this
matter uh for our purposes tonight i
think where it connects
is that like it or not we have just had
our boat rocked for the last year
no homeostasis was had it was it was
just
difference and but because of that
all of a sudden i think there's the
possibility that maybe for some places
where we were saying no to god suddenly
we might say yes um so
all of a sudden we get new perspective
on our life right because like it or not
change happened
and we had to learn some things we had
to face some things
in ourself in our relationships in our
world
and that opens up the possibility
of a more healthy a more vibrant new
normal
now i say possibility because it's not
like some guarantee you know that all
the changes will just be awesome
sometimes we react
in anxiety and fear anger you know so
there's all sorts of ways we can kind of
go haywire in a bad way
so the goal of this series is let's not
let's not go that path
let's go the better path let's um let's
have a better a more christ-like
a more god-centered um new normal so
at any rate that is uh the series and
so tonight the title of my message is
from busyness to wholeness
from busyness to wholeness our scripture
is going to be isaiah chapter 53 or
sorry 55 verses 1 through 3
and this is the lord kind of speaking
through the prophet
and you'll notice it's very poetic
uh the prophets we often don't think of
them in this way but the prophets were
poets
and i think that's that's beautiful and
powerful because
it can help um the message kind of ring
true for us even you know millennia
after
uh it's actually happened right even
when the people the audience
the particular circumstances that isaiah
was speaking to
have shifted and yet i think it can
still kind of echo
uh down through the the centuries for us
so um with that in mind let's go ahead
and read
isaiah 55 verses one through three he
writes come
all you who are thirsty come to the
waters
and you who have no money come buy
and eat come buy wine and milk without
money and without
cost and he starts asking questions why
why spend money on what is not bread
and your labor on what does not
satisfy and he says listen you can hear
the kind of he's like imploring his
audience like please
listen listen to me
eat what is good and you will delight
in the richest of fair that means like
the best of foods
give ear and come to me listen that you
may live now i have um
no idea how that just hit you maybe some
of you are like oh my gosh that is so
beautiful
i love that and others of you are like
yeah see this is why i don't like poetry
i have no idea what he's talking about
uh fair enough don't worry my hope is
that by the end of the message
um it will resonate with everyone um
so that's kind of the goal so let me
start here i've heard it
said that busy is
the new fine you all heard this busy is
the new fine
and you can kind of track in what they
mean right like how when you greet
people
right when it used to be i don't know
maybe 10 years 20 at some point it
started to shift right but it started
off yes someone like how are you doing
they're like fine
you know i'm doing fine and by the way
i'm actually not totally down on this i
know
you could kind of critique it like hey
that's shallow you always say you're
fine whether you're
or not you know and ah but here's the
thing like we don't just
you know literally every person like how
are you doing oh my gosh absolutely
terrible we just start pouring out now
hopefully church can be different right
we can get to know people and connect
and be honest
but i mean i get why in society we can't
go just
so my critique isn't so much the fine
thing like oh you're lying you know
uh i get it but it's interesting right
that it's shifted
we go from fine to now sometimes people
still say fine
but it started to shift right and now
what's the thing everyone says
busy right busy like how are you doing
busy oh my gosh so busy slammed crazy
crazy busy oh you wouldn't believe it oh
my gosh
yes the craziest week crazy week you
know just
we have like a million ways of saying
basically busy um
and that's it's just like the this is
just how we communicate
now it's almost as though we're all i
don't know like in the achievement
olympics in a way you know of like
because there's
there's almost a status thing with it
you know you're kind of weird if you're
not busy it's like oh my gosh what's the
problem with you when you have an issue
you know why are you busy
you don't have value in the world you
know it's like okay so there's kind of a
status thing that goes with it but
honestly i think at other times it's not
necessarily we're trying to one-up
people it's really just that we're
literally just real stressed out
because we're just like it's we're
really busy and we're kind of going
um but it is it's interesting how the
cultures kind of keep shifting and we
just keep kind of
getting the sense of being busier and
we're all in the achievement olympics
you know it's like the gold medal goes
to
i don't know whoever i don't i won't
pick on people but just
you know you guys are made like whoa i'm
going to pick on something okay the
branson's like amazing
the branson's like they have just
squeezed
the most productivity out of this week
way to go right like there's there's
almost this sense of
everyone's trying to just i mean even
the language in the culture you know
it's like
if you look up um articles on any like
business week or
inc or whatever it's just these constant
you know productivity
maximizers just maximize just squeeze
every last drop out of the day and how
to it's just like it's so intense
uh in fact there's something uh that
i've come across y'all maybe you've seen
it because of social media like hustle
culture
have you ever seen hustle culture like
and just to be clear it's not bad to
like work hard
you know that's not bad but there is
this sort of level that we're kind of
pushing it to
where it's it just seems really out of
balance so i came
i found a few um memes that i i loved um
not because i agreed but i just thought
they were hilarious so here's one
um i've got a dream worth more than my
sleep there you go like that's hustle
culture right like
yes i can imagine a medical doctor just
being like oh gosh okay no no that's not
that's not good actually don't don't do
that
um here's another one the dream is free
the hustle sold separately
yeah so intense this is hustle culture
it's all very
you know intense and you can see here we
got the um palm tree
and you know it's sort of the ideal
setting um
and uh yeah this is it's it's a
fascinating thing here's some statistics
um 75 percent of parents um in the
united kingdom said they were
um too busy to read to their kids at
night
that fascinating like what does that
mean when
as as a culture and my hunch is it's
probably similar in the us
um what does that mean when we're too
busy to like slow down and read to our
kids
uh 55 of americans don't use all their
vacation time each year
presumably this is talking about
salaried folks you know it's not like
unpaid it's like hey please this is part
of your job you get two weeks or three
weeks or whatever
we're like no i'm not using it at all
too busy too busy
um a 2008 poll by usa today it found
basically they kind of tracked this over
like 30 years maybe it kept going i
couldn't find a
you know continuation into 2020 but
through between 1987 and 2008 they just
tracked it
and every year over year over year more
and more people said they feel either
busy
or very busy than the previous year to
the point by 2008
69 of people in the culture said i feel
busy or very busy
um only eight percent responded not very
busy
not much i mean in the whole us like it
means 92 percent of people are like
yeah i'm pretty pretty slammed uh a
percent are i guess living their best
life and they're like they're loving it
um i mean it's apparently our culture is
going bananas um
or at least it was and then
the pandemic hit you all remember this
like the train of busy we were all going
we had a plan
we had a schedule the calendar is full
full chock full
every night is full and we're like going
and then it just
i mean it was like two days like i mean
kind of depending on
which crowd you're listening to or your
politics or various things that kind of
staggered for people
but you know at some point it's sort of
like the world just kind of like
and we came to this grinding halt
uh and i mean it was it was pretty
amazing
um at least at first you know there was
kind of this
this sense of um like
we just went from oh my gosh i'm slammed
busy crazy busy too
not that much going on i remember one
thing that shifted for us and our family
almost immediately um it was the family
dinners
you know like we i've tried to emphasize
that um but still
you know we weren't close to seven
nights a week and then all of a sudden
did y'all have this experience
of whatever your kind of group was like
all of a sudden there was like this
kind of time to like eat as a family
again
you know or eat with your housemates or
whoever you know you're in community
with was like wow
okay i guess you know it was almost like
it used to be monday nights were this
tuesday nights were this wednesday night
and all of a sudden it was like every
night's the same like go to work come
back
and uh okay now having said this it
of course wasn't necessarily true for
everyone right i think uh
depending on your kind of um you know
segment like if your
frontline healthcare worker this has
maybe been quite a hellish year teacher
i know we got a few teachers this wasn't
like you know oh yeah
jill year um all right so it's not
necessarily everyone
but but for i think a pretty large
percentage um
things started to yeah it slowed down
and uh and like i said at first man it
was like pretty great
you know um it kind of dusted off the
old board games and puzzles
did you all do some of that or you have
like i literally had to blow dust off of
the puzzles
um and then
uh you know things i think here's this
is actually kind of a similar arc as
last week
and then all of a sudden things started
to shift
like i talked last week about
relationships that at first like oh my
gosh to just have you know kind of
less people and things like it was kind
of a break
um but then over time we got lonely and
i think it was similar with the busy
like at first we thought oh yeah this is
great we just need to do this forever
um but then it was like
um we kind of realized that in ways
like if we thought that a slowed down
schedule
was gonna solve all our problems within
like a month
or two we realized oh
okay maybe not because
um it was like that old anxiety some of
those fears
some of those worries like it was
still there does that does that kind of
make sense
did some of you have this experience a
little bit like where it was i mean on
the one hand it was good to slow down
and yet what you thought would be a
panacea what you thought would be like
oh
praise the lord just like less busy yes
all of a sudden it was kind of like
oh gosh okay okay actually
i kind of need to keep going here i kind
of
need my busy a little bit
um like in other words here's kind of a
crazy thought
what if we aren't all victims
of our busy what if
we're kind of like inviting the busy
because we kind of need the busy
in other words what if dizzy
isn't our disease what if it's actually
our drug
does that make sense like it's the thing
we thought i'm afflicted by busy
oh my gosh this i don't know who did
this to me the world foisted busy upon
me
i can't do anything about it i'm a
victim of busy and then but all of a
sudden when it went away
then we're like oh gosh okay i'm
actually kind of coping
with all of the feelings deep inside me
with my busy i'm mostly avoiding all the
feelings deep inside me with my busy and
if i can just keep going
and never slow down enough to kind of
face myself and my feelings
that's sort of the best way to go
through life am i anyone tracking
like this i think this is a little bit
of what we're doing
uh you might say busy isn't our problem
it's sort of a pseudo solution
and don't worry for those of you
thinking i've forgotten isaiah 55.
don't you worry i will come back but
but i i really i want to set it up
because um
i think yeah i think this is this
actually gets to the root of
of some of what's going on in our world
and this is where i think there's a huge
opportunity in the last year
because we we thought if i could just
kind of like think of busy as like the
carpet in our house like if i just rip
out this old musty carpet of busy
then i think what i'll find underneath
is just the rock solid foundation of
peace
enjoy all the fruit of the spirit just
love peace joy goodness i just know i
just get rid of this whole carpet oh
it's gonna be great and yet that's
happened right we kind of
ripped up that old carpet and underneath
what was it it was like
anxiety things i named earlier right
fear
worry that kind of voice in the head i
don't know about you but that voice in
the head
i think it's interesting that the bible
calls satan the accuser and that's kind
of that like
voice in the head just that that speak
of that you're such a failure
you're not good enough and when i'm
unbusy it's like that voice just ramps
up it almost gets worse
you see i i think um we believe
that the opposite of busyness is
laziness
when actually what i want to contend
tonight is that the opposite of busyness
is wholeness that's the title of the
message right
wholeness from busyness to wholeness
you might say that busyness is less a
problem of the schedule
and more a problem of the heart less a
social out there problem and more a
spiritual inner problem does that does
that make sense that in other words
before
my calendar before i have the problem of
my calendar filling up and i feel like i
don't know who's doing this
you know it's like it's it's it's us
there's a thing inside us that
just might um need it
and this is why i found the passage from
isaiah 55 so completely beautiful
not because it clearly you know talks
about being busy per se like thou shalt
not you know
have too many to do's in that list like
clearly it's not it didn't say that
right
um but i think it gives such a beautiful
picture
of wholeness of
of a rich good full life
um let me read it again come all you who
are thirsty
come to the waters now again remember
this is poetry so
when he says thirsty is not it's not
literal right instead i think we
actually have a thirsty culture
you might say a very thirsty world
people are are like
just die and that's where i think a lot
of busyness is coming from
it's like i'm thirsty i want something
i'm lacking something i need i need more
peace i need more joy
i need more like stimulation i need i
just need something more
right so we're very thirsty come all you
who are thirsty come to the waters you
who have no money come by
and eat come buy wine and milk without
money and without cost
why spend money on what is not bred your
labor
on what does not satisfy can you hear
echoes there a little bit of the busy
of the why are you like spinning your
wheels
on what does not satisfy and you think
well if i could just commit to one more
thing
then i'd really feel like i'm
living life to the full you know he's
like why are you doing this to
yourself listen listen to me eat what is
good and you will delight
in the richest affair give ear and come
to me listen that you may live
i think um what god just might be saying
to us
is that we're kind of trying to nourish
ourself
on um junk food you might say uh
kind of the i don't know what the the
cheetos of distraction
the mcrib of striving that's the worst
poetry in the world by the way i just
did that's terrible
um get paradise 85 but
it's like it's kind of like we're
gorging on the cotton candy of
busyness uh when what we're really
hungry for
i think is i mean what is it it's god
sense of peace love
connection and this is what i love about
these words
bread water wine milk
i love that these words are so like i
don't know from the earth
you know like they're not processed
foods you know not not this is not
cheetos right this is like
the from the earth kind of stuff
and uh and i i so what i want to do i
want to actually kind of translate those
out of
kind of poetry and metaphor and kind of
into our lives
and then i'll be done so first let's
talk about bread
what's bread i'm going to say bread are
the things
that nourish and fill me can you kind of
see that in the metaphor
bread you know when you think of bread
it just fills you up
i mean people can actually if you make
it kind of the old-fashioned way can
literally
sustain people like for their whole
lives it kind of has all the amino acids
you need
it has all the nutrients you need to
survive people could live on bread
um not so much store bought bread today
but the old school bread that's you that
could happen
right so bread i mean it nourishes it
kind of fills us um
and so i guess the question is what is
it in your life
that nourishes that fills you what is
the activity the the thing you engage it
could be more of what you think of as a
spiritual practice or maybe it's just
something in your life
that actually god's offering that to you
as
bread and is it um
reading the scriptures
is it think of that uk study um that
poll
reading to your kids or your grandkids
you had that moment of like you walk
away from that time and it was just like
connection right they're sitting in your
lap
connection is it a coffee conversation
with someone where you go deep
you know it's not just like hey how you
doing oh doing good you know fine busy
you know
but it's like deeper that just might
that just might be um bread
for you what nourishes what fills you
god's giving that to you as bread
second let's talk about water water i'm
going to say this
is these are the things that refresh
that refresh me isn't that what water
does it's just like oh when you like
really need water
you ever had that moment where you wake
up at like 3 a.m and you're like
so thirsty and then you taste the water
and it's actually
sweet have you had this a few of you i
see preston carter yeah
like that's amazing right this is water
at its best it just
it's just what you need and it refreshes
it rejuvenates
you so i guess the question would be
what is it that refreshes
what rejuvenates is it
i don't know well you tell me what
refreshes
what rejuvenates you you can go ahead
and you can you can speak out i'm saying
it like things of like yoga
for me it's running i love that what
else what else for you
fishing yes you see that drives me
bananas
but i can see how like is there
something beautiful for you about just
like the quiet
yes just like the water um
yeah see i would go out on the boat and
probably just sit with you and just take
it in
like the actual fishing part i'm kind of
like i don't know but that's awesome
that's awesome yeah what else fishing
going on a walk yeah especially if you
can do it in a beautiful place
um a beach yes
that's that's water yeah that refreshes
yeah one more anyone what refreshes you
rejuvenates sleep
hey don't enter a i've got a dream
though
worth more than my sleep no um
yeah that's such a that's a powerful one
huh sleep
um all right let's talk about wine wine
i'm gonna say
uh bread water wine wine uh these are
the things that bring me
joy things that bring me joy it's
interesting that jesus first miracle
in the gospel of john anyone remember it
the water into
wine isn't that interesting that jesus
first miracle was to keep a party
going that amazing like i wonder if this
is how
people maybe who don't understand jesus
i wonder if like their perception is
that he would never do something like
that
you know or that but actually jesus like
was a person of joy
christianity i think at its best is a
religion of joy
i mean this is it's the best um so the
question is what's your wine
some of you are thinking my wine is wine
can that be my wine is that
sure i guess fine i mean whatever you
know um i certainly can't argue against
it from the bible
um yeah it's it's funny people i
remember being i was um
trained by all to say very conservative
denomination and um they i remember the
professor making an argument in class
about why the wine
of in the bible was like nothing like
the wine of today it was like way more
watered down
and i was thinking about jesus in the
miracle when he does that miracle water
to wine then what do the people say if
you remember the story
they say oh my gosh you like most people
you know
have like the good stuff early on and
then as people get kind of wasted they
bring out the cheap stuff
but you saved the best for last
yeah that that was not water they were
drinking
um yeah so what's your what's your wine
what are the things that
just bring you bring you joy
um and it's different than like a thrill
right or just cheap entertainment but
like true deep joy i know for um
my i was thinking of my my
brother-in-law and
i live with him so i know he that man
loves board games
oh my gosh um
i and i'm choosing some non-spiritual
things on purpose just so you know
um of course there's other practices
worship i got joy from this time you
know
but even simple things right board game
or like
two you had to kind of learn some
self-awareness you know and like learn
what do you love so my brother
he loves board games um he listens to a
podcast about board games
i didn't even know that existed but
there's a podcast about everything now
and he had like three friends over they
played board games for like three hours
he's like dude you want to play i was
like no
no man that's your thing um i wouldn't
write a book that was what brings me joy
right so it's different for every person
what what is it what is it that brings
you joy
and and might that just be like the wine
for you
god's wine just for your life
um finally milk milk i'm going to say
these are the things
that help me grow you know ultimately a
life of just water and wine
probably not great you know if you're
just like yeah like this is sort of the
idea of a perpetual vacation is better
than an actual perpetual vacation
because
you know it's like you can only drink so
many pina coladas on the beach where
you're just like what am i doing with my
life you know like
what's going on and there is a sense in
which we always
um we always need to be growing you know
we always we need some challenges we
need some places
um where we're we're kind of being
stretched and we're trying new things
we're pressing into new territory
and god's meeting us in the midst of it
when i think of
um you know a lot of um i think a lot of
work can be like this like good work
meaningful work
can be a place where it's milk
stretchiness growing us
um even i think a lot of work here
in church context it's often milk i
think of those
who are right now in that room with
those little ones
right it's it's not necessarily wine
they're probably not going to step out
of that
saying like oh my gosh it was such wine
you know it's easy um but what are they
going to say hopefully it's milk
hopefully it's i'm learning i'm
stretching i'm growing
i think of folks who um play on the the
team up here
and i know at times um they can be
nervous
right it's sort of like a stretching
experience what is that is that doesn't
mean it's bad
no it's like you're being stretched
you're growing
um maybe i know people run marathons do
you very you know like i don't know just
try hard things like what is that
i think that's that's milk it's milk
um mine right now is coaching soccer
that's my milk it's i'm learning to uh
how to yell without being angry
you know how to how to be patient
how to teach you know and it's
vulnerable because i'm not awesome at
soccer myself
i don't know i'm even learning the rules
but i'm the coach
right and it's it's uh i'm being
stretched i'm growing
so in closing um i guess i just want to
ask what would it look like for us to
leave the junk food behind
you know because what if our busy is
just substitutes for bread water wine
and milk what if it's just sort of a
junk food it's just sort of like keep it
going oh my gosh
and instead of kind of slowing down and
prioritizing and saying okay god
what's the bread what's the water what's
the wine what's the milk in my life i'm
gonna i'm gonna focus
in and that means some things might have
to get pushed to the side
but i'm prioritizing what you have for
me in my life
and we might be less busy then but i
think
more um full
all right let me pray for you lord jesus
i uh
i thank you for this community
and i i just i pray
god just for a sense of um just
self-awareness to kind of come over us
that we would start tuning in to
um what the bread is what the water is
what the wine is what the milk is in our
life
so that we could live full
rich meaningful faithful lives
lives of true joy
god would you do that work in us and we
love you
it's in the powerful life-changing name
of jesus that i pray
amen
all right we're gonna do this last song
together it's called lay it all down
and the first time i heard the song i'm
trying to remember if it was right at
the beginning of the pandemic
or possibly right before
um because it was in that season where
it just felt like everything was piling
on top of everything
and it just felt like a
um so
y'all just join in you can stay seated
or stand if you would like
whatever posture you feel like you'll be
able to reflect and
think on what brett's been sharing and
just open your heart to what god might
be speaking to now
bring your worry with grief and pain
every cause you have for shame
lay it all down
when your cares have buried you
and there's nothing left for you to do
lay it all down
lay it all down at the feet of
jesus
[Music]
i carried on but your heart was tired
feel the worst and felt the fire
laying it all down
lay it all down
and filled with all those anxious
thoughts
all your doubts become your god
lay it all down
lay it all down at the feet of
jesus
at the feet of jesus
[Music]
lay it all down lay it all down
lay it all down lay it all down lay it
all down lay it all down
all down lay it
all down at the feet of
jesus
at the feet of jesus
when we've given up on better days
there are memories we can't
it erase down
we've come to fear what we can't explain
there's nothing here that can ease the
pain
lay it all down
lay it all down at the feet of
[Music]
jesus
of jesus
lay it all down lay it all down lay it
all down lay it all down
[Music]
down at the feet of
jesus
at the feet of jesus
[Music]
down at the feet
ah
thanks you guys thank you so much for
joining us tonight
so glad that you were able to be with us
here and online
uh for those of you that are gonna be
joining the welcome to the table class
now is the time
as soon as i dismiss you can meet brett
right over here by the exit sign
and for those of you online you can grab
that google meets link that
brett sent out and he'll meet you online
at 7 30.
if you still want to be a part of that
online class email brett
brett at thetabletx.org and he will make
sure you get that google meets link for
the meeting tonight
also one of our values here we want to
be really communal
and so that goes beyond just meeting
here on sundays if there's any way we
can be there for you throughout the week
please let us know if we can pray for
you tonight before you leave
we'd like to do that for you if you just
need a listening ear we would love to be
that for you
please don't leave if you're in need of
that
and lastly as you go into your week let
me
uh bless you with this benediction and
can you guys
stand up for this
[Music]
and this is for each and every one of
you
you are a child of god
this is true on your best days
and on your worst days it's true for the
people that are
sitting around you right now and
wherever you are online
and it's true for those that you'll come
in contact with this week
so as you go into the week ahead with
its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted
just as you are and go
filled with the desire to extend these
same gifts
of unconditional love and grace to
everybody that you come in contact with
this week
have a great week we love you and hope
to see you back here next week
[Music]
lay it all down lay it all down lay it
all down
lay it all down at the feet of jesus
[Music]
at the feet of jesus
oh at the feet of
jesus
[Music]
at the feet of jesus